tras la inspiración del título 42
vuelven a regir las normas prepandémicas
en materia migratoria queda en vigor el
título 8
se trata de una legislación que tiene
años de antigüedad y a diferencia del
título 42 permite que los migrantes
puedan realizar su solicitud de asilo en
territorio estadounidense sin embargo
bajo la administración de Joe biden se
modificó para que solo puedan ser
elegibles las personas que hayan
transitado a otro país pidieran Refugio
allí y no se le otorgaran además ante
una detención por un ingreso irregular
conlleva castigos más duros si alguien
llega a nuestra frontera Sur después de
la medianoche de esta noche Se presumirá
que no es elegible para asilo y estará
sujeto a consecuencias más severas por
entrada ilegal incluida como mínimo una
prohibición de reingreso de 5 años y un
posible proceso
la Esfera política estadounidense
continuó buscando endurecer las
condiciones la mayoría republicana de la
cámara de representantes aprobó el
proyecto de ley hr2 que impone límites a
los ilicitantes de asilo y les exige
pedir la protección desde fuera del país
también reanudaría la construcción del
polémico muro fronterizo
los republicanos en la cámara de
representantes aprobaron el proyecto de
ley de seguridad fronteriza más fuerte
que este país jamás haya visto asegurar
la frontera es una de las principales
prioridades y es la prioridad de los
líderes detrás de mí Estados Unidos
afrontará una nueva era que según las
palabras del presidente vaiden será
caótica en un comienzo una reforma del
sistema migratorio es aún una deuda del
Congreso y la inmigración irregular
vuelve al centro del debate a medida que
se acerca el próximo ciclo electoral en
el país